hey I'm daav and I've been having some
body image issues lately like for the
past lifetime or so it all started when
I was 9 when the doctor's office I
remember asking my dad and doctor when
will my waist go away they just stared
and said well that's your body I've been
looking at my phones my scoops my
actually no looking's not right I've
been staring like I Sarah Facebook
expecting something to change just
because I'm looking at it
[Music]
I try to do the right things like
standing up straight wearing
high-waisted shorts working out and
avoiding mirrors I know I usually like
my arms and my legs but they're not
doing anything for me lately I feel
crumbly a lot it's maybe because
everything's become a little
unrecognizable
I was trying on some pants the other day
pants I've had since I was 23 and
instead of staying on my body they all
just kind of exploded the only natural
response after some anxious sit-ups was
utter self-loathing and the covering of
all mirrors like someone had died I
couldn't look at myself my shapes were
wrong
they've always been wrong and now I have
the pants to prove it isn't that
something
all it took to completely destroy my
self-image were three pairs of exploding
pants the shape I wish I was is 23 he's
a beanpole hair down to his temples
featureless otherwise and so perfect the
shape I am in real life is a total
mystery but the shape I am in my
imagination the one that I can see in
every mirror every photo everywhere that
one's a doozy I recently went for a walk
it was nice out summer day everyone was
looking great but I was feeling whenever
so I didn't really notice when this lady
stopped on the street and shouted right
nice legs I immediately thought that she
was referring to not me because duh but
then I used my eyeballs saw the holy
[ __ ] I was wearing shorts shorts that
showed my legs thank you I said and
thought Jesus dove no one is ever as
mean to you as you are to yourself it's
time for a change small as it was that
moment inspired about a year's worth of
trying something different
I am trying something different I am
trying to swear to God look at myself
differently I do this thing lately where
I draw I think I look like and then I
draw what I look like mirror I cannot
begin to describe how helpful this has
been in seeing my body as the world sees
it in grounding my shapes because I
first spend all of this time focusing in
my imagination drawing it heating it
that when I get to the mirror and see
myself maybe for the first time ever
it's a relief and honest to god
and maybe more satisfying than anything
else a recognition finally one body in
my shape it's a beginning for me there
are still photos mirrors reflections
that have the power to completely ruin
me by distortion and hypnosis but I can
now begin to see a different shape a
fuller one sum of its parts a shape to
break the spell I can be honest about
how I think I look and honest about what
I see it's tough to see what's really
there it legit requires training to not
see mr. ego because he's so easy he's
right there
but the other guy is there to promise
just got to look
[Music]
Wow